let's try our next caller from the eight
for seven area code caller from eight
for seven go ahead hi David
hey go ahead who's this my question is a
lot of people have made the comparison
between Trump and Hitler and there are
definitely something which people that's
a good question
but what about the people who elected
Trump and in general how do the how do
the jot die-hard tremors of today
compare with the people specifically the
German people of that time period
post-world War one both in their moral
integrity and their susceptibility to
propaganda and manipulation well let me
if I can for a second what do you think
is the similarity um well I don't think
we're quite there yet yeah I think it
probably some some fear mongering to say
that you know there's some big
differences but they're they're just
like with Trump and the Trump and Hitler
comparison there are some similarities
do you think we establish that Trump is
diehard trumpets
are 40% like the population of Germany
that supported Adolf Hitler in the early
20th century would that be principled to
us in some way like what would we do
with that I'm just I guess I'm
questioning what whether this is like a
good path right I mean we've identified
Trump's authoritarian tendencies and we
know that a modern day he seems more
simpatico with the authoritarian leaders
like Rodrigo Duterte
and Kim jong-un and president air Dhawan
but I guess I'm wondering like okay if
Trump hey if Trump ists have a 35%
overlap with third reich supporters then
what what do we do that well yeah I
guess it's all just kind of trying to
predict what's gonna happen in the
future
you know as far as you know how bad will
things get or you know if you're mopping
mistake how when will things get better
yeah I don't know I I hesitate to really
get involved in the in that question
because I just don't I don't know that
it's that useful you know I mean I think
that I've talked about how Trump asur
there's a few different
one's right there's those who voted for
Trump out of sort of a sense of self
enrichment that they believe Trump would
do good things for them regardless of
what they thought the morality was
there's people who were bamboozled and
tricked into voting for Trump because
they believe the things he said there
are people who just vote for whoever the
Republican is and don't really know much
else about it there there's all these
different groups and I just don't know
that we could ever really get an answer
as to how similar is the Trump
electorate to people living in Germany
during World War two I think a more
interesting yeah and maybe productive
area it would be what can we do in 2018
to take power back you know right right
all right thank you for the call I
really appreciate it an interesting
question but I just I worry that it's
not the most productive no it's it's a
big question yeah Godwin's law showing
up on David Pakman show life deed fourth
fourth call the deck